So that concludes this lesson.
It concludes the lesson on tracking.
It concludes what seems like months
of recording about tracking.
Somehow this ended up being a lot but
its really a cool part
of computer vision.
You have probabilistic state.
You have the notion of measurements and
the idea of combining those to come
up with what's really going on
in the world, which at its heart is
what computer vision is all about.
Also for many of you,
even if you don't end up doing computer
vision this idea of maintaining
a consistent interpretation over time
as something changes becomes important
whether you're tracking the state of
traffic flow over a bridge, something,
whatever it is this idea of maintaining
Interesting interpretation over time.
So some of the principles we
learned here from computer vision,
can be applied to those
more generic situations.
Anyway, that's it for tracking.
Onward and upward.
Pretty soon we'll start
talking about recognition, and
lots of other cool stuff.
See you later.